I think the notion that Barack Obama is
a radical is preposterous Henry Louis
Gates Jr who is quoted in my book as
saying that the only radical thing the
only truly radical thing about Barack
Obama is that he's african-american I
think that's true that his politics are
Center centre-left they come out of the
tradition of the Democratic Party in
many ways they're continuations of lines
taken by the Clinton administration you
know look at the health care bill itself
this is a more modest healthcare
building many proposed by others he got
what he could get and he succeeded look
at the so called radical nuclear arms
treaty just signed with the Russians
there's a lot of criticism on the right
saying you know Barack Obama is giving
away our security he is he is stripping
us of our capacity to project strength
in the world and to protect ourselves
and in fact the great left winger Ronald
Reagan was far more radical when it came
to nuclear arms policy remember
Reykjavik in the period of the Gorbachev
Reagan period where those two men were
intent on reducing nuclear stockpiles to
nothing and here we've reduced it by a
third I mean we they were the notion
that Barack Obama was somehow came out
of a radical cauldron in in Chicago and
somewhere in his desk drawer in the
resolute desk in the Oval Office is a
copy of marks and Gramsci and Lenin is
just obscene it's ridiculous and there
are just too many elements in the media
and in politics trying to stoke these
fires for those absurd notions to
disappear
it's very difficult to see I look I
think there is a legitimate conservative
opposition as you'd expect of course
that's going to happen is going to be a
legitimate Republican opposition that's
going to be battles what concerns me is
not that so much what concerns me deeply
is the outer edges of it and the nature
of the outer edges of it and the way
it's though the outer edges of it are
provoked by certain politicians and
certain parts of the internet and
television and cable television and all
the rest and the end result of some of
that kind of ugliness can be beyond our
reckoning really beyond our reckoning
and I don't want to be too alarmist of
it but I remember for example in Israeli
politics during its khakhra beans time
when the far right there stir things up
to such a degree that the that the
political atmosphere in certain quarters
became quite literally murderous so I
think we need to be very careful about
lumping everybody together in its even
the Tea Party movement I might not agree
with any of it but the extremes of it
are really alarming